well it's a las vegas spot not many
people know of yet
museum of selfies opened its doors just
a couple months ago
here's a look inside this trendy video
that you'll want to add to your
destination list
hey guys we're inside the museum of
selfies it's a brand new video on the
las vegas trip
that'll force your imagination to go
wild
from giant edible bites to a selfie
stick made thrown
the museum of selfies in las vegas is
getting more than likes from visitors
we feel like a kid i got my kid all over
again
the venue located along the linc
promenade recently launched as the
second in its franchise
but according to its creator it's one of
a kind our museum is a little bit
different we had a lot of like
traditional museums when you
can go and see different like stuff but
they never allow you to touch
things play with them do something cool
right so and we decided that we have to
create something different from that
you can snap a picture in this lavish
jet while pretending to drink champagne
as you fly into las vegas
or do several clicks on your camera
phone while bathing in this royal tub
filled with gold coins one of my
favorites this flipped bedroom
keep your hand in the middle of this
table this is your leg
and you will move it like this one two
three
perfect we will edit this picture
handstand
how cool is that yeah the museum also
claims to have the first
selfie ever taken and documented i have
a lot of like artifacts
from like uh you know for example like
1835 the very first selfie
which was taken the same way as we do
right now
robert cornelius did that using the same
way
mirror in front huge camera because that
time the cameras were so
huge right and he took a selfie the same
way as we do right now
[Music]
all right we will be sharing some
stories from our destination vegas
special this week
and you can watch the entire special
featuring fun places to visit
around the city it's on our website
eightnewsnow.com it was a
great assignment there yeah you took
some good pictures there christian